字幕志愿者 李宗盛
歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是陳愛倫
大家右創
歷史新考
要接一下是不是
好的 我想說你要很激昂的全部講完
沒有 我覺得很特別
因為我們每一週跟我們的觀眾朋友見面
結果呢 三月的時候都還在那邊
就被川普整來整去
四月完全走出一個新格局
是的 我們3月還在那邊說
哇 又跌千點 哇 又漲千點
對 海盜船嘛 都快吐了
沒錯啊 一下說什麼川普要打
一下說川普不打了
但是4月以來確實以戰爭的因素影響
整體的市場的那個
應該說什麼 利空出盡了
對 你看像我們美股
我們先講美股
除了道琼 全部創下歷史
四大指數嘛
忽然之間就說 都在年限就上來了
是的 那當然我們台灣股市不遑多讓
我們不只創歷史新高
我們還直接站上了
3萬6根 3萬7千點
是 因為之前很擔心
美股上不來的話
我們可能就要怎麼樣
南下跟它會合
幸好它來台北找我們
北上 坐高鐵北上
所以我們台股創下歷史新高
那陸陸續續有重量級的法說
台積電 大力光跟國具
最近被動元件很強
光學鏡頭也被大力光
牽起 一起帶起來
當然台積電從4月初
就開始在帶機油
有一起拉起來了
所以這次的法說
确实这些龙头们
感觉大家非常期待
而且很多的押宝行情
确实是有买盘的
好 我们第一季
角出了非常亮丽的营收数据
台股的商量会公司
有180多家是创历史新高
我们三月份的出口数据
也是一个历史新高
所以基本面很强劲
开法说的公司又告诉我们
下半年或是第二季
都是更好的
所以我们能不能往
四万点迈进呢
哎呀 加油
等一下来揭晓了
好 我们现在要告诉大家
我們台灣股市人創歷史新高
背後確實是有基本面支持的
沒錯 我們是有機之創高
沒錯 我們3月出口首度跨越800億美元的大款
800億美元 也是非常誇張
那出口額801.8是單月首次突破
較去年成長61.8%
快追上台積電毛利率了
哪一個國家出口可以成長六成
沒錯 很誇張 這根本就
我們去年就已經很不錯了
我們是高級期的成長流程
所以確實AI的爆發力道
至少在台灣來講
應該是非常受惠的
那手機的表現是1957.4億美元
年增率
這個叫去年Q1來講
50億吧 五成喔
也是真的扯耶
對啊 你看我們之前整個2023 2024
2025就在這個地方
突然在這個地方
發生什麼事情
對啊 去年四五百億
沒有今年八百億
所以我們的成長今年是極限的在加速中
主要驅動的產業肯定就還是AI
資通視聽 電子零組件 受惠AI強勁需求
兩大類都是同創新高
資通視聽 134.5%
三月出口年增 電子零組件年增44%
光是這兩個整體貢獻的出口成長
就有74%跟25%
所以這些都是AI相關
整個都包起來
另外當然出口市場其實結構一直在往美國做靠攏
這個應該也非常明確
美國Q1年增率達98.9%
出口比重原本是31%
現在是33.5%
這個又拉了2.5%起來
再來東協則是年增52%到了20.5%
整個的狀態投資資本的設備進口
Q1半導體大概進口109億美元
也是單季的性高
另外貿易順差呢 來到了530億美元
年增124%
這個數字都很誇張
難怪有這個外資機構
估我們今年的GDP成長
五個排分點嘛
好 IMF
不過我們自己就估7%了嘛
對啊
主機數跟央行都7%
所以至少5%嘛
我們往7%
保底保底
沒錯沒錯
那看得出來
其實光是Q1的數字
就已經非常的亮眼了
所以我覺得AI的發展
確實帶動台灣股市
應該都在台灣的產業非常的強勢
也反映在股市身上
好 我們看到下一則
下一則來討論的就是出口變動率
跟整體的消長貢獻率
誰貢獻最多
剛剛提到了
這裡103.6%
電子零組件40%
工學器材34%
有一些衰退的
可能是傳產
不過目前來說
整體都還是
這些是主要貢獻值的
另外主要的產地
美國81.3%年增
中國也是有50.7%
东西也是61.8%
整体来讲的话
其实我们对海外的出口的状态
应该都还是非常强劲
这是累计的
这是个月的
然后这边帮大家讲一下日期
2026 3月
2015 12月
1月 2月
这边都帮大家
那边有一个所谓第一季的累计YOY
没错 51%
几乎全面成长
只是幅度而已
是的 几乎这里
大家都要买我们东西
没错 台湾就是这一波受惠
因为台湾最厉害就是电子领主角
所以剛好我們的產業
可能在30年前強勢過一波
30年後風水輪流轉
再強勢一次
這個是跟大家講一下的
再來我們看到下一則
下一則跟大家討論的就是這一個
近期有一些報告在更新
那半導體相關的
我們今天幫大家做一個快速的更新
當然字可能有點小
那大家就是一樣
我們QR Code掃起來
QR Code掃起來
CG圖卡都是免費提供的
沒錯 我們現在看到的
伺服器跟晶圓代工
就是AI發展的核心
雲端巨頭呢
資本支出是創新高的
那這個應該大家都知道
而且Blackwell 黃仁勳也自己說了
未來入賓系列呢
我們接下來是要估一兆美元
原本是5000億
直接100%跳上去
那麼再來台積電的先機制程
壟斷
3奈米 5奈米全線滿載
2奈米估計2026年底會放量
Cole Wars呢
則是會目標要翻倍到
11.5萬到13萬片
一個月 月產能
好
再來重點公司當然鴻海三月創歷史新高
再來廣達三月也首次突破三千億大關
當然這股價是股價
我們先講的是產業面
所以目前來說這一些都持續在成長
再來另外一個是IP跟ASEC
ARM有跨足了AGI的CPU
潛在市場規模會有1000億美元
這個有利望去受惠
再來HBM4客製化這個有世新KY去受惠
Cowars呢 沒錯
那Cowars則是有創意會去受惠
創歷史新高了
所以目前來說這個確實
也在4月近這個禮拜的時候
整個ASEC相關的個股
確實是有強力表現的
好 那再來我們看到第三個
就是光通訊跟CPU
這還要說嗎
是的 跟大家更新一下
我跟你講全台股就靠這個CPU
沾到它就發光
沒錯 而且是往外持續擴散
他們說現在叫細光普照
沒錯 一下講的是
原本是那幾家嘛
什麼上全
然後後來轉到 聯亞 光盛
對啊 那個後面就轉到那個
零化音嘛 材料類
所以那個 穩帽啊 全新啊
對 然後接下來轉什麼
設備也有
這個 面板也有做CPU
面板也有 還有LED啊 木材啊
沒錯 噴爆
只要我有就是CPU
我就是標誤 只要跨足
網通也有啊
沒錯 沒錯
所以這個為什麼會這樣子
因為主要還是傳輸的問題
1.6T 往3.2T的發展之下
可插把的這種
原本的那個運輸 傳輸方式
已經來到一種物理極限了
那CPU呢 其實跟大家講
還沒有開始
我的意思是以產業來講
它今年第四季才會量產
那股價已經先飛天了
這也正常 賣夢
那再來細光子
像這個光學的精密的對準
還有這種飛波外星的檢測
這就是什麼
這個就是設備廠
裡面有智貌
旺系會是受惠的
重點公司有光盛
有波若薇
剛提到伊頭拉谷全部都是
所以CPO我覺得
後續如果有做一些整理正當的時候
應該還是可以關注重點族群
那當然短線長多
再來另外一個就是設備廠
PCB還有特用化學
目前設備廠
2025年的這個投資估計
大概210億美元
是全球第三名
PCB更不用說了
除了CPU之外
最恐怖的另外一個族群
而且延續性非常長的
就是PCB
PCB有上游的
有中游的 有下游的
有設備廠
那基本上股價都非常的強勢
那目前來說
主要的這個精神指標
還是我們CCL
就是中游的大哥 台光電
非常的強勢
另外一個呢
特用化學則是一樣
台積電在推動的在地化供應鏈
近期的表現也非常強勢
包含了像什麼光量科
這個雙劍 長芯
這種三晃等等
其實都有一定的股價的表現
那我覺得這邊都是以圍繞著AI
去做向下的延伸
那同時延伸到了
其實台灣很多公司都是龍頭
所以我覺得這個收費程度
我們剛剛講到的是出口
AI
那我們來看一下細產業
大概會是這一些發展性
我们的设备股其实
是一个脱胎换股
是的
因为以前我们叫半导体设备
但是本土设备的
就是所谓打进台译电工业的并不多
可是因为台译电有个计划
就是要扶植本土供应链
再加上PCB的崛起
因为我们有很多是PCB的设备
以前他们的股价都超级低的
现在都是本益比30倍50倍往上攀升
这个两大产业带动的
真的是不可同日而云
是的
所以其实这种是那个
我们就是那个嘛
30年一轮嘛
对不对
大家都重投胎了
錯過30年前沒關係
現在又重新可以來
沒錯 那另外一個呢
我跟大家講的就是這個人型機器人
這個還沒有取得市場上的一個
共同信任
但是呢有一些些相關的
一些小龍頭們在強勢表現
不能算小龍頭 上銀算小龍頭
應該說有點個股表現
像大銀尾
沒錯 我們來看一下
但大銀尾也跟那個
半導體
也有切到CPO
對
好 摩根斯大利認為
資测會有預測
2026年是人型機器人的
大規模生產的起點
那麼2026年是商業化的元年
27則是有機會規模化的放量
那主要是商用工業端
那2028年才有機會
我們才有消費級的
旁邊跟一個秘書的
那個我覺得可能要更久
好恐怖
30...2030...
我一直對人型機器人覺得...
不會...他只要長得可愛一點就可以了
我指的不是很正或很帥
它可能是一個小動物
所以才會有那種比較矮矮的
對啊 小動物型的嘛
那個就蠻可愛的
對 好 沒關係
我們就看有沒有瓦力
可以跟在旁邊嘛
那人型機器人有五大產業
五大系統
一個是感知系統
就基本上是視覺處理
這個就是
我覺得已經算心臟了
因為你看不到
你根本就不用做東西
所以視覺處理
跟感測模組的優勢
那再來呢
這個控制還有決策的系統
那這個東西呢
主要就是NVIDIA
跟其他AI晶片的龍頭落地夥伴
提供的就是運算平台
還有系統的整合
再來就是執行跟驅動
這個是台廠比較強勢的
馬達 或者是線性傳動等等
我們會 我們會
是 然後再來是機械結構還有材料
這個減速機
精密的外面的外建跟外殼等等的
再來另外一個就是能源
這個就供應
要電還是要電
好 希望不要只有台達電
其他的電也一起來
沒錯 這邊也幫大家簡單放幾家
像是AI视觉的
有所罗门
感测器模组的有炎华
光学有哑光
哑光去年也很强势
再来工业电脑
有还是炎华
世纪雄整合有达明
旗下的子公司
再来核心精制造
就是台积电
然后像上营
台达电 全球传动
这些基本上都是
比较有代表性的个股
我们看到下一张
下一张我就帮大家准备了
吓到了吧
什么东西
对
對
怎麼叫本週六早上9點怎麼了 人家去哪我幫大家準備了剛剛提到幾家關鍵的我幫大家準備了相關關鍵供應鏈比較完整的機器人概念
那明天 不是明天 週六早上9點
我們Lightight就會走
是明天沒錯 我們禮拜五晚上播出
所以如果想要索取完整的關鍵供應鏈
我們可以加入Lightight
除了剛剛節目所有的資料圖卡
還有等一下大禮賓等等的
以及艾倫今天有設計了一個禮物
我剛才突然看到
請把我們的LiOT 掃起來
就會獨家知道
到底是哪一些機械人幹力股
這是低位階還沒有發動的
是 在下一段開始之前
我們迎來了第一段節目的重點
就是台積電的法說
剛剛都還沒提到
沒錯 我們快速的
跟大家講一下數據
因為數據我覺得
應該大家都已經看到新聞了
就是營收年增40%
毛利率62%
EPS22塊 要求
全部都是歷史新高
那先進製程呢
7奈米以下的營收高達了74%
也就是說其實成熟製程
台積電真的是越擺越旁邊
那當然啦 因為先進製程嘛
第一個 毛利率肯定比較高
那可能需求是更爆表的
所以台積電 Q1的營收
又是以去年相對高基期來講
之下的歷史新高
是
非常的非常的恐怖
那再來呢 Q2
有說到了 目前來說
這個營收預估是390億到402億
已經要再多50億出來
再來毛利預估會是65.5到67.5
那全年的目標依舊是調升
就是30%以上整年的目標
這個數字很恐怖
目前的技術研發還有產能進度
2奈米他們有說到這個進度是超前的
在科學園區準備量產
2026年就有機會貢獻明顯的營收
再來A16的製程一樣在下半年會開始量產
那這個東西呢 就是針對AI跟HPC的一個最佳的方案
再來先進封裝 坦炎啦 雖然產能倍增啦
但是呢 我們CC會還是說啊
AI瓶頸就是在我們身上
好 因為不夠用嘛 博通講過啊
博通說 跟產業電拿產能 這個是現在越來越困難啦
是 所以它是瓶頸
有一本書就在講這個事情
真的喔 好帥喔
就是瓶頸 他就是瓶頸
講得很帥
然後另外一個全球布局
亞利桑那州第二座晶圓場呢 準備開始進擊了
下半年 明年的下半年会量产
在成熟制程转型
我觉得这件事情
可能对成熟制程来讲
应该也算是利多
然后这个强调成熟制程
不追求量的扩张
它追求的是什么
高价值跟特殊化的应用
也就是说
如果你想要大量的
你可以找别人做
我们只追求了
就是高质感的东西
或者高毛利的成熟制程
我觉得对其他的成熟制程来讲
或许会是个利多
那另外一个地缘政治
因为关税
他也是说了
就是我们会有弹性的定价
那是什么意思
客户会付钱
对啦
对不对
成本就算高起来的话
客户还是需要
刚刚讲产能都抢不到了
没错
那另外一个当然就是
我就已经去美国设厂了嘛
对嘛
我就是要避这件事情
所以我觉得这件事情
对后续的影响程度应该不大
但是我们在上个礼拜跟大家讲
我觉得台积电
跟台积电相关的供应链
你在法说之前
可以去介入
没错
但是法说完之后
我认为会有一些
短线的获利的这个调节会出现
所以后续大家还是要注意一下
我觉得这个是短线的获利调节
但是如果有整理
股价我们说现在股票很难买
那如果这一波有整理下来
只要形态没变
而且出现止贴讯号
其实我觉得应该是一个
重新去上车的好机会
是 对
好 所以我们刚刚也跟大家分享了
台电的法说
虽然数字都很棒
不过因为现在市场的期待
都是比较高一点点的
所以严格说起来
也许算是有点点的中规中矩
但是我们刚才也看到了
不管強勁的出口數據
或者是營收數據
都帶動的台灣
如果下一波股市有稍微回檔
您喜歡的個股有稍微回檔
都是好介入的喔
當然下一段的話
艾倫就要來告訴大家
到底介入哪一些族群
或是現階段最好的選擇喔
好的 來吧
我們今天幫大家講兩個相對低位階
跟一個PCB強勢族群裡面
找一些我覺得還在相對低檔的地方
好 貼心的高低配
沒錯 我們先看到了低檔
低檔來跟大家講的就是這個誰
這個誰 誰啊
誰啊 出來了
上癮
不是 你在叫什麼
反正以為你要念一下
沒有啊 機器人啦
機器人是位階低的
是的 可是大家要相信機器人嗎
剛你算你講了很多
其實我跟大家講
因為我現在在找族群的時候
我剛說股票很難買
所以我在找什麼低位階
現在DV界有幾個
一個是機器人
那另外一個是重電
聽起來都
對
但我覺得這一些東西
聽起來都傷過我們的感情
沒錯啦
但我覺得
上癮型態是有打出來的
但是上癮跟大癮尾真的還蠻猛
沒錯
所以我們可以看到
這一個上癮
目前來說
整體的表現呢
形態上出現了一個
大紅K的突破前告
對
那這兩天呢
在高檔稍微做一些震盪
但是可以注意喔
今天下跌
量能萎縮
所以應該是賣的人不多
健健康康
對 所以等均線跟上
我覺得這個剛打出來的一個大底部呢
是有機會讓它有一個延續性的表現的
而且呢 這個停順點我覺得也相對好抓
你看五力均線跌破
或者說這一根大量有沒有
的最低點跌破
那可能換手失敗
好 那我覺得就可以做調節
那目前來說的話
形態我覺得剛轉折
所以我覺得可以關注一下
好 上銀 畢竟大哥他真的要表態
現在各組群都需要有大哥表態
沒錯 我們再來看到下一位
下一位呢我們來講的就是蒙莉
蒙莉集團的其中一位
他這個呢就是做協波減速器
前一陣子其實表現還不錯
他有創一波反彈新高
但是呢跟著3月的時候
一起下來休息
那休息到今天呢這跟紅K
這個小的圓弧呢
跟這個下降趨勢線呢
基本上都做了一個突破
那這兩天在整理的時候
雖然都開高走低
但量能是萎縮的
所以我覺得
都還算是可以接收的狀態
那就後面等這個均線嘛
現在五日均線剛跟上
如果十日均月線都開始做一個
上彎的黃金交叉
應該就有個動能
可以去推升它的股價
至少我們先來挑戰
這個前高的狀態
所以我覺得盟利目前來說
下降趨勢線
剛佔回全部均線
位階偏低
有機會在這邊做一個好的停損
均線跟上
其實我覺得有一個賺培比
所以這邊盟利也跟大家講一下
好 再看到下一位
盟利希望他能夠學學觀藥科
就你前面牛沒關係
你來一波大的吧
真的是好牛喔
跟半導體也有關
我們來看到下一個龍頭
我們介紹一下龍頭
今天是牛牛大集合
沒辦法 最近比較牛真的還比較強
還不錯啦 他有創歷史新高了
國劇這一次一樣
國際大廠包含國劇自己也算國際大廠
都在喊漲價 其實在喊很久
你看喊漲價
可是到這裡
终于这一波让它喊涨价之后
股价做了一个突破
最近的法说讲完之后
整体的向法人都是调升到380
甚至有到400
所以有目标价的调升
我觉得不管是需求量的增加
当然另外一个就是
他们原材料的上涨
包含像是金银 铜铁这些
对他们来讲都是成本的
都是成本
所以都要转嫁给客户
所以就调涨
调涨这边一样跟上银很类似
大型态的高点压力区
相形压力区
刚刚去做突破
今天回测五日均
直接拉一个长长的下影线
所以目前来说
这四天的成交量都放出来了
我觉得未接也不算高
因为刚转折
那转折完之后
回测完今天的低点
或许就可以试回
你想要介入的停顺点
目前来说
我觉得未接刚转折还不错
再来看看下一位
下一位就是这个金山店
讲完大的讲小的
金山店之前有标过的
有标过
其实目前
像金山店或者說其實很多被動元件
最近表現都很強
小型的 小型很強
什麼和聲堂 什麼鋸頂
我沒有注意到鋸頂
我有看到和聲堂 四根
也是這樣噗噗噗噗上去的
很多啊 九毫
可是像比較熱門的
包含了 或者說大家耳熟能詳
前面很強什麼九毫啊 蜜望石啊
這一次也有漲
可是就很容易在漲的時候
盤中會有賣壓下來 斷斷續續的
對 那金山店其實也有一點類似這樣
因為之前在講彈池電容的時候
就是谁
有讲到他
没错
那金山店近期呢
今天的股价盘中有一度
涨了七八个百分点
被压下来
对 被压下来
是有上影线
但是一样
我们找的都是这种低位阶
相形平台刚做一个突破的
然后呢
高点去做突破嘛
全部均线站回来
所以我觉得这个位阶
也不算高
对 那不算高
全部均线慢慢要跟上
我觉得形态打好了
后面行情不要太弱的话
被动员件持续有族群性的话
其实我觉得金山店
是有机会继续做表现的
是
這個是相對低位階的
好 再來我們看到下一個
就是高階的部分
好 這個PCB裡面本來它相對落後的
結果現在也是一個標
沒錯 其實我們等一下那個好股回顧
也會再講一下高階
你到底多愛高階
但是我覺得高階
因為我們之前跟大家講的
這邊開始在回戰季限
成交量有放出來
然後或者是說
以基本面 產業面來講
這個出貨開始順利了
好 順利到這個地方
高點也做突破
當然我必須說
这边的位阶有一点
至少在这五六天的行情来讲
小偏高
毕竟刚就没有什么明确休息
都是均线去跟股价
可是我觉得未来
以现在来讲的话
你跟金像电比
你跟电影投控比
其实我觉得位阶都不算高
当然我们可能也不是说
听完之后下礼拜马上去买
而是说这边均线跟上
如果开始有做一些震荡
我觉得还是可以去注意一下
有没有重新上车的机会
这个是提醒大家以下的
那我们来看一下下一个低位阶的
就是男子电
我正想问一下男子电
汉语柏拉
精神科
是有蛮多PCB里面反而是在休息的
是的
像精神科最近形态有好转了
对 可是我觉得
可能可以再等它转一下
对 就是你有指纹
你有底部涨停
可是那个即便涨停
可能距离季线都还在努力中
对 所以我觉得那个可能就可以关注
但不会马上是
我觉得就有机会发动的状态
那我们来看的就是男子店
男子店其实之前也有吵过一个话题
就是他在中国有户店
户市店
户市店 对
所以目前来说这个题材
我觉得对于他的业外收入
应该还是会有基本面上的贡献
那目前来说以男子店来讲
这个刚来到了前方的大量压力区
所以再消化一下卖压
消化卖压中今天来到了缺口110块附近
就有拉一个下引线
也就是说消化了卖压之后
底部还是有人承接
那有承接我就会觉得
如果你可以去过这个高点
如果能够过这个高点
那就是一个漂亮的换手成功
那也是一个大的底部
做一个压力区的突破
到时候形态打出来
我觉得也就可以像国具
或者说刚提到金山店一样
有一个形态上的确立
那我觉得对于未来的
这个反弹的力道
我会比较有兴趣
或者说会比较期待一点点
所以男子店
我觉得形态差一点点
但是可以注意一下
这几天如果有做一个转折突破
那或许是一个好的形态转折
好那这边的话
就是我们今天有帮大家分享的
到底有哪一些
因为艾伦他比较着重在台股虽然创稿
可是有没有所谓的热门产业
却还低位阶
我觉得用这样的角度来想的话
那台股的机会就还蛮多的
那下一段节目我们有带来宾
他带来的是
如果你台积电觉得涨多了
会在法说会后回荡的话
其实有一些台积电们
更值得大家做布局
歡迎我們今天的大來賓也相信是我們節目大家很熟悉的常客冠军操盘手云翔哥
大家好
云翔哥又来了
大家知道在三月的时候
云翔哥有来分享
当时因为国际局势比较动荡
台股也一直破月线
破季线
所以你是减码持股的
但是四月来就发生一个很猛的事情了
你只要买选择权的HOOD
台股就会大涨
一路涨到今天
已经过了三万七千店
但是呢
当台一店的法术会开完
你决定要减码
为什么
我大概先来讲一下
就是说分享一下
大概三十页这个做法
因为其实在之前呢
大概这一段
我讲到这一段来讲
你会发现说
只要大盘
我还是比较偏重
以家庭指数来讲
是看这个季线
季线之上我就认为说
它就是一个多头
那如果它站在月线之上
代表它是一个
比较强力的一个多头
所以在这块里面
就是说我大概是
这个季线之上维持五成
月线之上就大概保持七成
所以一直保持这样的行为
那其实前面一段来讲
大概只要落入这个区间
就会减码
然后再重新站回
所谓的重新站回是这样的
大家看一下
就是说重新站回月线
你会发现一件事情
其实上来要功过
这个所谓的潜高
一般来讲它的量
就会跟着追随上来
所以在这一段你就发现说
其实这个所谓的一个
功过这个所谓的前高
那量基本上需要一个
比较强的量了
那这一波来讲就是说
在这个位置点
也一样就是说
三月份之前
真的是非常强势的夺头
可在这一段下来以后
这个基本上是长黑黑下来以后
量急速缩下来
其实这时候我就觉得说
大概有一些危险意识
所以大概把这个持股
大概整个降下来
大概维持最多不超过五成
那这一段里面就是说
当然后面也会讲
就是说我就会操作一些
比较安全的一些机制
包括说这个旋谷上面
可能跟以前有一点不一样
我等一下会来讲说
大概怎么样的一个做法
那最近来讲
刚刚赵华讲就是说确实
在这一段来讲就是说
大家可能没有想象说
这个战争可能会
这个摊飞了对不对
所以川普敢把事情谈非
谈崩了
但股市没崩
对 股市是非的
所以那一天上海
基本上我觉得说
以这一段来讲
我们刚刚提过的嘛
就是说
它的动能只要跟得起来
那我觉得说
我就应该遵循了这个所谓的轨迹
一样就是把这个
这个所谓的持股
把它加上来
那这一次基本上
加的比较足的原因是
我认为说
其实在这一段
攻上來以後
你會發現
台穿的這個力度很強
很強喔
台穿忽然活起來了
所以我台穿是賣飛的
賣飛
可是賣飛的
基本上我的持股反而是增加不少
是
對
那一直持續到大概
這一段
這個大概
大概持股幾乎都是滿倉
本來是七成
滿倉啊
幾乎是滿
滿倉很驚人
等於是我把這個放在
滿倉是九位數了
對
好
那今天這個
不是今天 這個位置點來講就是說
今天週末這個位置點
剛好我們講說這個台積電法縮出來
那剛剛趙華提到說
為什麼會這樣止步
對啊 你有什麼意見
原因其實這樣 台積電來講
就是大家知道說
在台積電的這個法縮前
其實通常股價都先動
這一次也是
對 過去來講
已經是很多的一個跡象是這樣子
這一塊來講
大概我們從三月份開始做
大概就一直引用這張圖
原因是基本上很多人都估得出來
是我只有估得出來
大家都認為說
台積線近年要看90塊很合理嘛 對不對
所以最高可能看到100塊也有人估嘛
所以如果90塊來講
大家都已經想像說
第一季至少要21、22塊
所以剛好也符合這個數字
沒錯 結出來22.04
所以如果以這樣來講
就是說持續他講說
第二季可能增加30%的營收等等
那可能是真的有辦法接觸到
接近EPS 100左右的一個位置點
所以當時我就拉了一個這樣的區間
那這個位置來講 我認為說
台積電從當時的這個區間
最低點大概1800
得了已經漲到2100
當時還小破過1800
但是只要1800你覺得就是便宜
所以我認為說這個已經
反应已经完全满足了
对 那既然这样来讲
就是说它回挡的机会
当然也会变大
不是说它不好
也就是说前面这里来讲
就是大家这个估值
已经达到标以后
通常我们讲说
这个数字走在前面的情况下
这个股价走在前面的情况下
当数字出来
它有可能会稍微回落
所以我只是稍微
真的把这些资金稍微
拉回来一下
等待下一次的一个进场点
当然因为它这一次很特别
如果它都没有涨
搞不好法术会后表现不一样
但这是偏偏又先涨了
但是如果假设这一次跟以前又不一样
是继续涨那怎么办
买回来
我大概先谈一下
以这一块来讲
当时我们在讲说三月份过来
那时候是看指数的一个行情很不好
所以那时候我大概台具店
就坚持做一个所谓的区间
区间操作
这一次
这个区间做真的是
有做到了
为什么
因为区间总共做了六次
六趟
六趟总共
收益来讲
大概本金大概是一千零多
等于用六张的这个本金左右
那赚了大概接近三百
所以等于是大概三十趴
是
对
那这一波来讲
等于是它最高
台阶是跌了八趴左右
那到这一天
刚好这个所谓的指数喷过以后
那我直接
最后一次的结仓结在1940左右
所以直接就卖飞
那我觉得卖飞了以后
其实我本来就有设了一个剧本
跟大家分享一个剧本
就是说这一段来讲
如果没有卖飞的情况下
那也代表说整个局势还是
混沌不明
基本上它有可能还是延续了
这个所谓的区间
我认为走的可能性还是很高
所以如果我就这样
就持续做这样类似的一个区间走法
可是如果它能够卖飞
那也代表说
整个这个所谓的大盘
应该会往上冲的机会就高了
所以卖飞了
那我应该就会增加我的这个持股
可是就不会在台积电上面
因为我把它卖飞嘛
可是我就可以把它拿来做什么
台积电门
也等于是就算啦
就算之后刚好它都没震荡
这一次偏偏就上去了
也一样就把中小型加回来
对 加回来
加回来就对了
对 加回来就对了
所以以这一次来讲
确实在这一段来讲
我觉得是有做到我的理想的做法
剧本
包含就是说
整个卖费以后
这个批基本上很快
基本上就是当场买了以后
要看一周嘛
我都只看一天
一天就亏零
所以这一段来讲
就是正好也有讲
只要影响一个大买
而且是买很多
以前是十万
现在都搞到会二十万
三十万四十万
所以這一波應該有燒了大概七八十萬的坡
七八十萬的坡
都是打水漂歸零的
但現貨市場就大賺了
對 所以這一段沒有關係
就是以這一段來講 當然是有賺
那做法我可以看下一張
就是說 基本上我覺得說
總體來講 我是抓到大概最近五天
等於是噴出以後的這五天的一個交易日裡面
你會發現說總體來講
其實最強的還是在台積電門
就是說這個所謂設備股
對 然後封測股
設備封測 玻璃陶瓷來講
對 包括這個所謂
像富橋之類的
還有金居 也很強
對 那PCB的材料
這應該是比較偏金居的
還有CCO這一塊也是非常強
所以總體來講就是說
IC的設計當然是屬於台積電
像這種晶圓製造
那這塊來講就是整個台積電相關的
基本上這一波來講
漲幅非常兇猛
包括日月光都已經充100塊以上
那另外來講就是一些漲價題材的
也在動
所以之前修正很多的被動元件
這一波也直接就創高
所以等於是我就盡量朝這個方向
然後把資金壓住比較多一點
在這一塊
包括台積電被動元件我當然也有進場
那另外來講我就避開
绿色这边的
对 为什么避开
因为总体来讲
这是一个资金净流入
净流出的一个概念
所以当这个低润的股票
的资金在流出
也代表什么
可能这些资金流出
它会流入
所谓的这些涨价题材
所谓的台积电
相关的一些族群
所以这里来讲
我就暂时先把它放开
不代表说
它一定是不好
可是也代表说
近期来讲
它可能是一个
比较有修正的一个状况
那如果以这样来看
我们先看一下
比较不好的
看下一个
先看比较不好的
因为我想记忆体有很多人都觉得
南亚科开了所谓的法说
第一季赚了八块多
明明就很棒
展望也很好
可是股价就是起不了
对 可是本来它的现行就是这样
基础分别也这样
它本来就已经是在高点以后
走的一个下降轨道
回到了
因为之前都在讲上次轨道
讲下降轨道
那下降轨道你会发现说
确实只要碰触到这个
所谓的下降轨道的上源
基本上它就可能下来
所以这一波你可以看
就是说以这个
我们叫龙头的南亚科
因为南亚科
你会发现这一波台股大涨之后
它基本上比这个涨的那个起点还落后
也就是说涨了四五千点
它基本上几乎没有动
而且还下来
那这一段来讲
不但没有往上
它等于是这个轨迹下来以后
它还跌破的月线跟季线
所以以这样来讲
当然我认为说短期可能是
它往下修正的机会比较大
就先避开
那会切入到什么呢
我们看下一章
就是说
基本上我刚刚提到
第一个可能封测
因为从机体流出的钱蛮多的
蛮多的
所以大型股也动了
对 封测来讲
就是说像日月光就不用讲了
只要台积电好
只要台积电的资本支出多了
那一定是封测
基本上它的量就会起来
营收竟然会成长30%
那相对的这个封测的股票
以日月光就是一个龙头
是 世界第一的龙头
对 所以这一天就是
大盘起涨那一天
比如说如果你这个所谓台阶卖飞了
那你在这个起点去切入到
比如说像日月光
那你基本上这一段不比台阶差
那所以如果我来讲
就是如果看高坐低
那也是一样的做法
如果看日月光
那我可能是比如说看细个
好 比较中小巡步
那细个来讲
它是走一个所谓的上升轨道线
所以这里我们自己也提到说
这一天也就是一样
就是等于是卖飞的那一天
它也一样在这个点
基本上它等于是穿过
所谓的上升轨道上远
所以这一段来讲
他当然也有机会
赚到一波
不错的一个短线的收入
那以这些来讲
就是说当然现在来讲
我认为说
可能可以找一些
比较没有发动
所以还是
下一章还是看历程
你真的是历程
历程
我还是挺
辛苦
这是可能还是很多人
一直把它跟记忆体
有点绑一起的关系
其实大家知道多题材
对
那什么时候才能好转呢
对 我觉得现在
为什么会讲 特别讲这一句
基本上 因为前面的那一些基本上当然中小勤鼓跟风策什么有关的基本上都已经大概喷飞是对 那唯有它还在所谓的一个打底的阶段因为前面的那一些基本上当然中小型股跟风测什么有关的基本上都已经大概喷飞是那唯有它还在所谓的一个打底的阶段因为前一段打底
碗形底
基本上这个碗形底
很漂亮嘛
对不对
突破以后
确实还是有涨一波
那这波有可能是
因为它还是有联想到
一些低润的相关
那时候有
对
那这时候
基本上它又打了一个碗形底
对
那这里来讲
当然它还没有过景线
我觉得说
这是一个布局点
不是说现在就要进场
也就是说它是有机会布局
那为什么要叫它布局这样
基本上你可以发现说
整个封册里面
刚赵函有提到
其实我们讲说DMN来讲
它做的不是传统的DMN那一块
没有错
它是未来跟美光做的是
HBM高阶这一块
所以今年看很好是
高阶这块HBM
加上说它本来一些子公司
它也有切入所谓的COAS相关
HPC的相关
甚至未来这个FOPOP
这块它本来就已经布局好了
所以它等於是在切入
這個台限相關高級還是有
所以我認為說
如果今年人家估它14塊多
明年估到21塊多
那這個位階來講
我覺得機會點還很大
需要點耐性
因為可能最近投信
還沒有趕快回來補貨
對 投信之前把它賣掉了
現在看它要不要回來
對 所以這個是封測的部分
另外一塊當然講到設備
因為資本輸出現在看到是
560億是
大家也是估法
是估高标嘛
对不对
虽然他没有调高
因为现在是
这台电影很严格
希望调高
但没有调高
但还是很多
看到亚翔
他又创历史新高
新期又上了
对 因为
大家看了可能是
大家很希望他赶快讲
明年后年的数字
太坚肯
他不想这样讲
第二季很难
对 明年后年
可能他很多人
把他估值说
这三年的估值是
下半年才会讲啦
将近两千亿美金
对
那我觉得说
也不用看了这样子
因为明年他一定要
资本数要增加
因为你新的制程进来
那亚翔这一块就是说
他确实就已经达到六百多块了
对不对
所以他又是创高的一个状况
所以之前我们当然也有讲
凡轩
对
因为他等于是这个洪海相关集团的
那这里面来讲
就是凡轩他是刚好在三角收敛
刚突破的那个点
那突破以后呢
基本上我们讲完以后
那几天基本上
他是越过所谓的前高
确实这个行为来讲也代表说
因为这个所谓的比较小型一点的设备股
基本上他们在手订单很多的情况下
我觉得机会点当然会大
对 因为那时候讲说
在手订单真的非常多
那这里面我觉得说可以再看一支
看一支就说
他基本上在手订单也很多
可是他股本也很小
看下就是信宏科
为什么特别讲
因为这些股本还接近5亿而已
小股本的东西
而他在手的订单大概有超过60亿
是
对 那你可以试想
就算两成的一个股本而已
那它预估2026年的EPS
达到23块多
也很合理
因为基本上这个数字应该是达到
所以23块多
对它现在的这个股价来讲
它本益比只有大概12倍
那比起亚强跟反讯来讲
它的本益比当然估值比较低
那这一次做什么
基本上它不只是做所谓的什么
什么无城市或积电相关
它主要是做什么
特化相关的一些所谓的系统
租送的系统
所以它基本上
信宏科来讲
它有跟什么
跟新印材
跟南宝
合资的一家叫做
南宝宏
新宝宏
对
那新宝宏那一家来讲
基本上它等于是切入
比较高阶的这个技术
等于是应该切到两纳米以下
所以以这块我认为说
有这样的一个
未来的一些前景
加上说它本来就是一个
三角收斂的钢突破位置点
离前高也还有一段
所以我觉得说
以这样来讲
就是说量钢发动以后
这些所谓的设备股
应该会跟得上其他
也是一样看高桌地的一个做法
好 其实设备股很少
现行长这样的
很多设备股都要又上角
对 又上角很多了
那最近有个气体书说
应该叫细科红尘
也长很多
那他也是
大家都还没有发现的话
也可以来参考一下
好 今天非常谢谢云翔哥
台积电卖飞没有关系
他买的是台积电相关的好朋友
而且一贯的就是遵守着
看高做低又找的是高EPS的好公司
大家花点耐心应该会有收获到
欢迎回到赵华
阿伦说
那我们又来了这个
大家喜欢的一个单元
就是追踪验证
我们讲过的股票状况如何
其实上礼拜我印象很深
你去检验的所谓六大全资股
没错
结果里面除了红海以外
红海其实也有涨
大家表现都很好
而且有好几档创历史新高之外
有一个还V转
对啊 其实我们等一下跟大家讲
谁V转
对 等一下跟大家讲谁V转
我们先讲一下
之前来三月跟大家讲过的高际
上礼拜其实有追踪他
对 可是目前来说
其实我现在觉得台湾股市
因为我们创历史新高
其实我觉得现在股票会偏
比较难买一点点
因为都涨上去了
对 所以今天来跟大家讲
就是我们之前来跟大家讲的时候
还是没有创新高的嘛
但是到今天回来看
其实已经突破这个平台的位置
也就是说其实高级目前来说
整个的状态它已经短线涨多
然后短线涨多
我觉得就如果有的
你可以选择抱着
比如说五日均线
或者说怎么样的再去做调节
可是你说如果现在要买
我觉得好像也不用这么急着买了
对 因为它已经刚过高了嘛
那刚过高很容易都会有一些解套卖
像如果在这一天买的
这一天原本是涨停板
这个黑K
然后后面变跌的
就是它是涨停后
灌到收黑K
我觉得大家最不喜欢
对 所以它为什么会这样
因为它来到前高附近
那要前高附近
这一定套牢这么久的
我一口气倒给你
那如果换手成功
隔天才算是一个明确的换手成功
对 所以来到相对这个位阶
我觉得建议如果没有了就不要了
那如果有了
你可以选择抱着
然后如果形态有重新整理完
我觉得要买的人再买就好
这个是高级
上礼拜追踪
還是這個個位數的獲利而已
對
結果這禮拜就變成將近四成的獲利
沒有錯 所以它的爆發力非常強
那我覺得PCB其實爆發力應該都蠻強的
我們來看下一檔爆發力更強的
這一檔我們就把它當成精神指標了
當初講它的時候就覺得也漲不少了
但因為跟大哥比起來還有點落差
現在這個漲幅也不輸大哥了
其實不輸喔 對喔
現在已經接近千元了
因為整個的法人同顧們都把三雄
就是包含连3D
有连帽这个目标价
全部都调升
他也叫哥了
三哥
三哥不好意思
本来是
还是很强势的
对像台光电影
有的目标价
喊到四开头了
那台要是喊到一开头
所以目前来说
其实都有一点点的短线
我觉得跟高级一样难介入了
那难介入
当然我们就不急着介入
如果后面有整理的时候
那形态重新整理完
我觉得再介入就好
对那一样
如果你那时候底部
是有一起买的
那沒關係到這邊也沒有轉弱
沒有轉弱我覺得也不用急躁的說
這邊是不是要準備獲利調節
有轉弱再調節
這個是台藥的部分
是 再看到一個就是
是不建議乾脆就去買聯帽呢
聯帽長得更兇啊
可是他很慢才漲耶
但是 他有點像當年探針裡的雍智科
有一點點像
就別人漲了好多倍
他還在原地打轉
他還才漲
對啊 可是如果是聯帽
我覺得近期也漲多耶
對啊 那個
只陡峭的
200多塊而已
人家也是100塊開始
對啊 也快100%
我一覺得就等等
像這一股
所以我才說比較難買
對啊 因為你知道未來很好啊
可是來到這個地方
我到底要怎麼買
我建議
閉著眼睛買
眼睛一閉就過去這樣
好 我們再看看另外一個是智邦
智邦我們之前也來跟大家分享過
那目前來說
也是創下了一個
近期的一個新高
它最近很陡
沒錯 所以目前來說
這個狀態我覺得都一樣
有的就抱著
其实它位阶我觉得还不算很高
因为这里是一个平台
刚突破没多久
我们讲在快要突破的那个时候
是的
那目前来说刚突破
所以我觉得这个反而相较前面两位
就陡峭的邪率就没有这么夸张
但也还不错
我觉得可以持续去追踪
这个智邦嘛
好难想象
因为它好像最近Meta跟博通
也要联手的关系
比较来说就在加持
最近力都蛮多的
对 所以我觉得相关的龙头们
应该都可以持续看一下
智芳也要2000元了
沒錯啊 今天有碰到202050元
那這個是以前
發哥
被超車然後一度落難
結果我們上禮拜點名他之後
還說會不會V轉
就給你V轉
真的超V
是的 我覺得連發哥
因為近期其實IP或ASX相關的
其實整個全部都在做全面性的反彈
好像我們發哥才剛碰到前稿
你去看隔壁的那幾位
什麼創意啊
力旺啊
千金的IC設計類
哇 那個
可是人家是純IP啊
還是有點差別啊
對 因為聯發科之前很多利空
一下子那個
它是輝達供應鏈嘛
輝達直接跟別人合作嘛
所以呢 股價就
剛好那時候行情全值也比較辛苦
但是這一波行情
整個全值拉回來之後
利多就浮現了
然後V轉已經來到前高附近了
所以目前來說
我覺得目前以聯發科來講
當然短線啊
每天5-6%的漲
短線一定有漲多的利率
但是你說位階來講
其實我覺得發哥目前的位階
不算高
畢竟可能我前幾天才剛
站回全部均線
然後目前來到前高附近
所以前高附近呢
看一下這邊能不能有一個
換手成功的狀態
那或許還是可以期待一下
後面的表現
是 你講的位置已經算不錯了
因為你說要在黑K最低點去買
那有點接刀子
沒錯
我們那時候講的就是
下降趨勢線破壞
對 就是你講的事情已經站回來了
沒錯 所以那時候我覺得
這個形態就已經在跟大家講
就是台積電也是類似這樣形態
才V轉起來
所以相關的這個技術分析的
那個破下降趨勢線
其實我覺得非常好用
就你知道它基本面好
那你知道它的業績也很好
未來展望也沒問題
可是股價開始在走回落
如果有一個轉折出現的時候
那都是一個值得介入的
就算後面繼續跌好了
你也敢抱著
所以我覺得下降趨勢線破壞
是非常有用的一個東西
好 當然發哥那時候
你會回答和Intel有做聯繫
那最近馬斯克也要跟Intel合作了
但是也在台語電的法說會上面
這個CC位也直接說
沒有關係我不怕
馬斯克跟Intel合作
因為一個晶圓廠要好
兩到三年跑不掉
而且那還要兩率TOO起來
所以這個直接就告訴大家
雖然馬斯克很厲害
可以把火箭發射上太空
但是晶圓廠還是我們最厲害
如果需要今天節目所有的圖卡資料
还有包括你有送一个小礼物
就请把这个Light 8给扫起来
我们会免费提供
要记得点进去之后
会在右上方的一个叫做记事本
而且不断是今天的
过去的每一集的念
都还放在里面吗
没错
很念旧的人
没有 就懒得在动
所以大家的话
记得把这个Light 8扫起来
那有什么意见也给我们一点鼓励
那我们的兆华
艾伦说
就到这边了
下礼拜再会了
拜拜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive